we had the season where everybody had a
girlfriend
probably miss your girlfriend in canada
off roading
justin you're gonna regret this and
ultimately just
one permanent thing a tattoo
i actually got a tattoo yeah this is
your the bachelor greatest seasons
ever season one episode seven recap grab
your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
oh babes how are we how are we i'm tired
what a day it was monday to get the news
that tasha adams said replace blair
crawley as the bachelorette
of course had to vlog and bring you my
quick take and i am just so excited you
guys what do you think
after peter's hannah's colton seasons it
just looks like we're going to get even
more shocks and twists and turns i
cannot wait for the season of the
bachelorette what does this mean for
claire
well from what we know we will still see
her on the show and we're gonna have to
find out what happened i don't know if
she fell for somebody really fast
or was talking to them beforehand these
are questions these are rumors we must
see
she was in the quarantine for like four
months so we're gonna have to see so
many mysteries and by the way sometimes
you guys wonder how much i know
the answer is i don't want to know i
want to watch the show as a fan with you
so tell me what you think okay what you
think of tasha
and claire unprecedented i love you guys
i got another one okay bye
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
here to recharge
yes everyone we are back with another
episode of the greatest seasons
ever after being on repeat for a week
and you know what
i've decided that after a repeat we
are going to recharge and also just
literally my phone is dead and so i have
an external battery here but if i may
wax poetic for a moment don't we all
need
an external battery in 2020 don't we all
need
not just a recharge but a reset
because this year has had us on repeat
and you know personally and i'm sure
many of you feel like this
i feel that even though i'm working and
still living i've been in many ways
on pause and i'm ready to lift my finger
off that button
yeah instead of pause i'm ready to hit
play
i'm ready to live i'm ready to be myself
so today is about recharging
so that we can resurface do you see what
i'm saying
if not have some wine that'll make it
more clear and on the note of starting
anew and starting fresh
i'm doing something that i've never done
on this show before
and i'm not going to do it again don't
go crazy i will still be drinking rose
with the occasional chardonnay and every
so often a red
but today i am drinking a sauvignon
blanc
yes a blanc because we're gonna wipe the
slate clean
and now let's hit play on this episode
let's get to it
so ally fitotowski's season of the
bachelorette
i did dabble a little bit in watching
this one and i can't believe how long
ago it was
2010. it has been a decade
since this show happy anniversary ally
and ten years later this season holds
up what did you all think of ali
fedotowsky's season
let me know in the comments below i mean
it had all the elements of
the bachelor franchise that you want
don't drink every time chris harrison
says drama
there is a lot more man drama coming
your way i told you the man drama
is good the drama unforgettable man
drama post dramatic departure in
bachelorette history
more man drama man drama right off the
bat we meet a couple of the key
characters first there's frank passion
is so much more important than money i
love you ally
and he says he loves ally and that's
important it's gonna come back later
don't forget it
i'm gonna win her heart and then there's
the wannabe professional wrestler
rated r i am mr rated r
yeah and he's got a broken foot he's on
crutches and that's gonna become
important later so don't forget it
and frank was enthusiasm out of the gate
he said he could
visualize his future with ally she's
going to fall in love with me i'm going
to fall in love with her
we're getting married and speaking of
visuals
i want to point out frank's glasses
i just gotta call it out because i can't
really remember anyone else who's
ever made it very far on the bachelor or
the bachelorette
who regularly wore glasses can you
let me know in the comments below i'm
here a hundred percent for
her then there's rated r the only
wannabe professional wrestler who's ever
been on the show
of course the question would be is rated
r
here for the rated right reasons
i'm absolutely here for the right
reasons spoiler alert he was not
don't drink every time someone said he
was not
i just don't know that he's here for the
right reasons see one thing
she sees something else true jekyll
and hyde i think he's just rated
dishonest really
just don't trust him rated i don't
believe a word you say
i'm calling him a fibber but i do have
to say something
and it's not in defensive rated r
because he definitely wasn't there
for the right reasons i'm the real deal
why are we
ignoring frank frank came on the show
wanting to be a hollywood screenplay
writer a number of years ago i started
screenwriting
and i fell in love with it they took em
and alley on a date
to literally sit at the hollywood sign
you can't even legally get there very
few people
can do what frank and i are about to do
next it was very cool i don't know how
they pulled it off
passion and if we look at some of the
things they were saying
frank wasn't even making sense he said
something about how he'd come on the
show
now because the career could always
happen but love couldn't wait
i feel like career will always be there
and i feel like we can
always jump back in to that i feel like
you only have so many shots at finding
love
what what why i will not be watching
your movie frank
i think that love and career moments can
happen at any time in your life
i mean how many people do we all know
who found the true love of their lives
on their second or third big
relationship
how many people do we know who found
their passion later in life
who recreated their career in a second
chapter
spoiler alert i don't think frank ever
made it as a screenwriter
what do you guys think was frank there
for the right reasons
was frank being frank and by that i mean
like was he being real with ali not like
was he being himself
so we have rated r what the prank
and now it's cool casey
i'm here to guard and protect your heart
yes another iconic franchise character
was
on ali fitowski's season don't drink for
every
quintessentially bachelor world
thing that casey did first he told ally
and i quote it's just my heart jump in
and stay a while it's just my heart
jump in stay a while
but then he took his words to lyrics
and sang to her my wordless on the beach
in california
i don't know what casey's job is but he
wasn't a singer
so casey's made weird proclamations he's
done
awkward things casey then did the most
quintessentially bachelor worldy thing
and i'm gonna do something that i would
never in a million years thought that i
would be doing
it was so on brand because he branded
himself
yes the bachelor is all about
proclamations of true love and longevity
and going on the journey
well casey put the journey on him he got
a tattoo
for ally i got the tattoo i did it
i'm proud of myself
[Music]
yeah casey shows the
tattoo to the other guys and don't drink
for all the silence
while they look at it
yeah casey tries to explain it he had
consistently told ali he was there to
guard and protect her heart
garden protect your heart and so that's
what the tattoo is
and you know i do think this was
something he had said his grandmother
told him
so it wasn't necessarily just about ali
but more about like a love
philosophy but he uh he did put a rose
in there didn't he
uh chris who would become one of ali's
final two said
you know casey you're gonna forever be
the tattooed bachelorette guy
you're gonna be the tattooed
bachelorette guy for the rest your life
that's gonna be probably your nickname
you know what ten years later here we
are chris was right
we love a chris we stand at chris smart
guys
[Music]
and you know what let's have a little
fun don't drink every time
casey said he was going to guard and
protect her heart
guard and protect your heart i'm here to
guard and protect your heart
and protect your heart came here to
guard and protect our heart and protect
our heart
always going to go and protect ally's
heart and protect your heart
[Music]
and i don't know why he said guard and
protect
those mean the same thing
so we've got a lot of potentially fake
dudes for ally fenitalski
and we're back with a two on one and
it's somewhere cold
but also fiery honestly it's scary as
hell
where the on earth does it exist that
you're gonna be freezing and yet facing
fire at the same time
iceland the pits of hell that's where
this two-on-one took place
the pits of hell iceland kind of like
2020
this place yeah take the finger
off the pause button okay
you know what i don't even want to say
my fingers on the pause button because i
didn't put my finger there
it's that the machine malfunctioned and
put me on pause but you know what
i'm now gonna get some tools i'm gonna
fix it i'm gonna start playing again
i'm talking about vcrs do you guys know
vcrs when you're watching this
i'm like definitely referring to vcrs
does everybody out there know a vcrs
everybody had a vcr
and do you remember the like rewinding
that you had to do actually they had a
separate machine for speed rewinding
if you want to watch a movie a lot you
could like because rewinding a vcr took
a long time so you could put that
vhs tape in the rewinder and push rewind
because if you're going to bring your
videos back to blockbuster
they needed to be rewinded and on time
because you're going to get those late
fees do you know what i'm talking about
let me know in the comments below okay
pause pause pause yourself
so we're on this hellish two-on-one date
at the ice volcano
and it is rated r versus cool casey
and ally says that all casey has to do
today
is just be normal the only thing casey
has to do today
is be normal cut to casey today's the
day that i'm going to show all my tattoo
casey push pause okay
[Music]
casey is telling ally the story of him
getting the tattoo i
actually ended up doing something kind
of kind of crazy kind of fun and
something that will stick with me for
the rest of my life and he is showing
her the tattoo
and don't drink for all of ali's faces
during this
i actually got a tattoo
she's like yeah yeah what
what that's really special
that tattoo is really special thanks
casey thank you casey
for being you for um
[Music]
being you and by for being you
she means showing me that i don't want
to date you
that's all i can really ask for so now
rated r and cool casey and aggravated
alley spaces are all as
beat red as this fiery volcano and their
bodies are as frozen as this icy snow
and allie fedetowski seems pretty fed up
because i have never seen someone so
unceremoniously deliver a rose
she's like i'm gonna give justin the
rose i'm gonna give justin the rose
doesn't need my waiting in the
helicopter absolutely
and then they leave casey
on the glacier so tiny and alone there
he's like can't really move his arms
it's like who's gonna get him
another 20 20 visual alone and trapped
thanks and now believe it or not
we have an even bigger moment but it's
not at a volcano
it's not on a glacier it's in this hotel
room
yes hey chris wistani chris
chris harrison has gone to see ali
fedotowsky and is telling her that he
has something important
for her to learn i do need to tell you
though something that uh was brought to
our attention
and he picks up this device
[Applause]
and i don't know if many of you out
there will recognize it
it's a landline they only
sometimes have them now in hotels you
may have seen one
on your travels when we used to travel
and chris tells ally she has to get on
the phone with
rated r's girlfriend
i don't even know where to start yes
rated r
had had a girlfriend at home the whole
time
ratadar had been dating someone for two
years
me and justin have been dating for the
past almost
two years now and went on the show for
his
career i'm going on a show but it's
solely for the purpose of
getting my foot into the door of the
entertainment industry
and ali fitowski iconically goes
and drops this bomb in front of all the
guys
you know justin i think it's been
especially difficult for you cause
you probably really miss your girlfriend
in canada
she called me this morning really
don't drink for all their faces
and rated r justin just leaves
no no no sit down and talk like a man
first of all
no because justin walked so colton
underwood
could run now grant and justin only
walked because he did have a broken foot
it was still
in a cast as i told you the crutches in
the broken foot would become relevant
later so that's why he's
he's walking at a fairly slow pace
actually he's limping and kind of
hobbling um he revealed in his zoom
catch up with chris harrison that he at
one point had to hide behind some blinds
to try to lose
ali and the camera crews and i hid
behind uh some blinds
it's kind of a slow chase you know chris
harrison ran after colton
he's barely moving briskly here
don't drink for every place they chase
him they're going down the hall
they're going down the stairs we're
outside on some cement
justin you seriously gonna walk away
from me we can't get through that door
so then we go through the bushes
he's like ally ally ally
could ally leave me alone ally just no
it's not real she's she's lying
i'm no i don't want to talk turn my mic
off i okay
yep okay i'm
i'm not gonna talk i'm ugh
at one point he's in a fountain
and i don't know if he can get that boot
wet allie finally
catches up to justin after his evasive
maneuvering and
he tries to argue that this woman is a
friend
she's like someone that i would say is
like my best friend
what did you think of that rated r for
really really not really really
not don't drink every time ally tells
him to
be a man and she's not wrong no
no no sit down and talk like a man
justin tuck like a man
you could have just owned up like a man
justin owned up like a man
and then and then
and then production
pulls an absolutely savage
move before there were dms
before there were online dating apps we
had
voicemails and as
justin is limping away one final time
the editors played not one but multiple
voicemails you know during this process
you are by everything yes this is justin
talking to his non-girlfriend
friend but ahmed she loves her and wants
to marry her
next saved message
honestly you don't know how important
you weren't
how did they discover this i would
imagine the girlfriend
gave production the voicemails but we do
catch up with rated r
hey how's it going chris he reveals that
he was discovered
because producers apparently always
remove
phones from hotel rooms but they forgot
one
in the bathroom you guys normally take
out
uh the phones out of the rooms and you
guys miss the one in the washroom i mean
you want to talk about old school have
you guys ever been to one of those
hotels
where they have like a wall phone in the
bathroom
i've never understood it who are you
calling in there
and you know what don't call me from
there i don't want to speak to you while
you're using the bathroom
why are you spending so much time in
there push
play don't pause
get affair but we are going to move from
a broken
foot to a broken heart
we've dealt with just moving justin and
now we've gotta deal with
gin frank okay
so frank at this point on the season was
very loved
especially by ally you can see it all in
this
one moment everybody ally and frank on a
one-on-one
frank in his glasses they kiss
frank pulls away ally's eyes
stay look how she is looking at him
the look of love frank's wearing his
glasses
but he's not looking at all his eyes
and his heart are somewhere else
as my feelings for ally have grown these
feelings inside me have been brewing for
my ex-girlfriend nicole
yes frank revealed he was having
resurging
feelings resurfacing feelings
repeat feelings his heart was on pause
for an ex-girlfriend named nicole
an ex-girlfriend that ali doesn't know
about but they put ali through hell
to iceland so they take her to paradise
tahiti and she's probably thinking this
is heaven
things are looking up but everything's
about to go
down back to hell frank is gonna break
up with her
he goes and tells her that he went and
saw nicole
before i came to tahiti i went to
chicago to see nicole
and that he still has feelings for her
the second i saw her
all the old feelings kind of came
rushing back
does anyone on this show not have a
girlfriend
this is the last thing i ever thought
would happen freaking
fake frank not even wearing his glasses
in tahiti by the way oh what do you have
contacts frank convenient all of a
sudden i don't really i shouldn't speak
about his visual problems i i'm pretty
sure that i'm actually legally blind i
don't know if any of you have contacts
but i
um do and if you have a number on your
contact lenses i'm like an 8.5 and i get
a 8.5 so my vision's actually pretty bad
and like i do
wear my contacts during the day then i
definitely have to wear them at night
because when your vision is that bad
especially like you really have to let
your eyes breathe and even with the best
kind of contacts and your eyes aren't
getting the oxygen
they need because it's still a piece of
plastic it's um a barrier onto your
eyeballs so like
no judgment on frank specifically for
the eye
glasses contact lens thing i don't care
about that it's just but like freaking
fake frank
so he's telling her everything and ally
is crying
she throws away her shoes
ally throw him away he's throwing your
love away
oh she's gonna leave i'm gonna go
i need to deal with this somehow but she
does pick up her shoes
i think she still needs those the sand
is probably quite hot
oh she didn't put on the shoes though
that's interesting she's just going yeah
she's just going oh it's because she's
gonna sit down and cry more yeah she's
gonna cry okay
what did you all think of what frank did
here
to me it seemed very obvious that the
relationship with nicole was probably
fairly recent
why would he have had these feelings
research as he did frank you shouldn't
have gone on the show
it's so good to see you chris i've
missed you and frank's here now and
we're catching up with him
he chooses to go on about how hard
that breakup was for him
that was it's still one of the hardest
things i've ever done in my life
frank let me be frank with you
you need perspective it was brutally
difficult to go through with that put
the glasses on
for your mind okay anyway what did you
think of what frank had to say
he did confirm so he didn't technically
go on with a girlfriend like rated r did
but he had broken up with her only to go
on the show
i was nominated for the show and i
met nicole and so we started
dating and i said if i get selected to
be on this show
like we're done oh god we've been
through so much that i forgot ally still
has to find love
believe it or not after all that there
are still
two men left and they are actually very
unproblematic and girlfriend free
great roberto and of course
chris i have to let you go here
and not wait till tomorrow but ally does
let chris go and he actually gives one
of the best responses i've ever seen to
someone being dumbed on the show
i mean i did learn to put myself out
there which is nice because i haven't
done that in a while
and then ally says like did i just throw
a really good guy away i'm wondering you
know
am i making the right choice this is
such a good guy i love hugging him i
love being around him
i don't know allie did you what do you
guys think let me know in the comments
below allie
not having the best judgment at this
point
having a hard time seeing the forest
through the trees if i'm being honest
everybody needs mind glasses we all need
them can someone invent that
it's 20 20 modern times we've got a lot
of new inventions can somebody
come up with that mind glasses
i think that's called therapy
okay i want to share my life with you
share your life with me ultimately
roberto proposes
will you marry me oh my gosh it's very
lovely
but spoiler alert they're not together
they lasted a little over a year
but he is now engaged and ali is now
married with two
very cute little ones so we raise our
glass to ally and kevin and their babies
yay
what did you think of ali fitowski's
season of the bachelorette
let me know in the comments below
all right everybody i love you so much i
am on tick tock
cameo twitter and instagram
and we will be back with another episode
next week
this one is gonna be a doozy i'm gonna
have to get one of my favorite roses
because it is going to be jason nesnick
season oh you thought that peter weber
was a lot
jason nesnick yeah the og wtf bachelor
okay i love you guys thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Music]
bye